what the hell are you delay captain
waiting sir
waiting for what private Dawson who the
hell is private Doss
I was dreamed about being a doctor but
uh near my school I can't stay here
while all them go fight for me what you
figure this war is just going to fit in
with your ideas well everybody else is
taking life I'm gonna be saving it
that's gonna be my way to serve this is
a personal gift from the United States
government designed to bring death to
the enemy I'm sorry sergeant I can't
touch a gun
you don't kill no so you know quite a
bit of killing does occur in war private
das does not believe in violence do not
look to him to save you on the
battlefield
I don't think this is a question
religion I think this is cow is not with
you because you are like anyone else
they're saying you could go to prison I
don't know how I'm gonna live with
myself if I don't stay true to what I
believe with the world so said on
tearing itself apart
don't seem like such a bad thing to me
to want to put a little bit of it back
together private dose you are free to
run into the Hellfire a battle without a
single weapon to protect yourself
I'm go get you home
there's something you gotta see
I did this thus the car
but if they go back up tomorrow
and then I'm gonna go up there without
you
Oh trust me
you better come on to me
all these Lord
help me get one more and then being last
to care of their business hold a folder
backup